Yes. Woo. I finished breaking bad. Woo. White, my,
my arms white as, but it's also lumpy. You know what that means, man,
your boy chin-ups. Yeah. It's why he doesn't go outside because he's inside.
Don't chin ups. I'm a prisoner inside, dude.
Just have you seen prisoners workout, bro? First of all,
this talk about breaking bad in, then we'll talk about prisoners working out.
I saw some prison workouts on YouTube and it's unbelievable, dude.
Those are the most fit. Jack dudes on the planet.
How come black dudes in the prison are so jacked.
White dudes in prison are either so frail or fat as and all.
I mean it's unbelievable, dude, white guys in prison.
If they're jacked, they're also fat.
They have a belly black dudes they're so top heavy. They're always running.
Cause I can't help it because they're falling over, dude.
I can't believe black dudes in prison. They're so jacked. It's unbelievable.
But let's talk about breaking bad. I finally watched it and this is very timely.
My babies, this is very timely.
I know the show ended in 2013, seven years ago,
but your boy just watched it.
I was waiting for a time to watch it because I don't watch shows like that.
I don't just continually watch. I don't watch all seasons of anything.
The only thing I've ever seen every episode of is actually missed one episode of
Dexter. But besides that I seen the whole on Dexter.
And let me tell you something, man.
I was talking about this on the Brogan podcast. I did this,
I did this last week. We were talking to Rogan about it,
but I think shows can only be good for about five seasons,
maybe six seasons dude.
But the second you do your walking dead it the second year. Just like,
well let's just keep going and keep making money.
And Rogan brought up a popular, uh, um, a very good point.
You don't want to end the show because all these people working on it,
that's their livelihood.
And you don't want to end the show creatively just because these other,
that's what they get their job. That's where they get their paycheck from.
So you've got a guy who's holding the mic. He's just like, Oh,
this is the last season. Okay, cool. Guess I'll sell my place.
Like you don't want the guy holding the thing or the ladies holding the bagel,
putting out the spread for craft service. Oh this is the last season. Well,
okay. I'll move to van Nuys or this is the last season. Okay.
Well I'll just move to the outskirts of Atlanta.
You don't want to do that, dude. Let me tell you right now, man.
Let me tell you right. Now, if I ever get a show on the air, my show,
I'm talking about my. Now we're on the lead where it's my where I produce it.
Okay. Um, I'm doing two things.
I'm doing one of two things.
I'm either stopping it four seasons in and getting the out.
I just making some that hits the desert Geist hopefully.
Or I'm running that into the ground. I'm doing,
I'm talking. I'm I'm talking about, if it's a hit, I'm doing 12 seasons.
And they're like, well, what do you think? I said, we got more seasons. Really?
The lead character isn't even in it anymore. By the way,
nobody in the original show is in the new sh is in the show.
If it goes 12 seasons, they've all died. Either of characters,
killing them or natural causes in real life. And we don't even explain it.
They're just dead. And we're like, Oh, a new guy's playing them now.
And then that guy dies. Cause we have to kill off the character.
And then there's just a new cast and the show becomes about something else.
Like dude, if I was making the walking dead, how's this for a YouTube clip,
dude. If I was making the walking dead,
that lasts about six seasons and then the cures.
I don't give a what happened in the graphic novels. It doesn't matter. I get it.
Graphic novels. Okay. Everyone's going to be like, Oh yeah, but what about this?
No matter what is not true to the, I don't give a.
It's not true to it because this is a different medium.
Your boy is different on his podcast that he is in you,
that he is on stage at stand up. You want the raw real deal. You get it here.
You know what I mean?
You want a hot flames performance to get it there on stage.
If you want me tied up acting my chops off, dude,
then you turn on you. If I take a graphic novel,
like walking dead and I do it for six seasons,
then it becomes the biggest show on television.
Like it did guess what the virus does.
Seventh season is cured and then everyone starts to get new jobs and then it
becomes a office comedy. And if you think of dude, if somebody did that,
dude, that would be unbelievable. They all got real jobs.
And now all of a sudden they're like working construction and it becomes a
movie. It becomes a TV show about like, uh, the,
whoever the lead character is at that point has a construction job.
And he's trying to keep his family afloat in the times of, of like,
it's just a completely different show.
And half the idiots out there don't even know what the they're watching anymore.
They're just like, Oh wait, the walking dead is all.
And I'm going to change the title to by the, by the 11th season,
I'm changing the title. It's called construction.
That is what shows need to do. Stop drilling it into the ground.
Oh really? Walkers. Oh, they're walking around.
Let me get someone gets bitten. Let me guess on an all new walking,
dead someone we love gets bit N that.
Cure the virus and put them all in Kinko's dude.
No more frigging zombies. Just
[inaudible]. Hey, got those copies. Cool. You know what
? You're going to get fired. If you keep on up. I know on an all new walking dead, what's the guy's name? Rick, the main guy,
an
all new walking dead. Rick gets his pilot license and starts flying for American airlines. All right. Got
a buckle up. Hopefully you got to understand.
They're stewardesses.
And we swear now cause it's on a completely different channel on HBO.
stewardesses are coming by with drinks. So take your order.
This is a cashless system. When you did your cohort with the chip.
Yeah.
We've got a four hour and 12 minute fly.
[inaudible].
Hi.
What seems to be the problem? My wifi doesn't work. Let me fix it.
Whoops. Blank falls. Cause it's a comedy about airplanes now, dude.
Oh, I figured it out. your show. If it goes seven seasons,
seriously breaking bad guy in and out. Dude. Breaking bad.
Got in and out. The dude was a up chemistry teacher. Oh,
what do I do to save my family? I know I'll cook meth. Bam. First season,
second season. Oh. I mean over my head. Well I don't, I shave it. Bam.
Second season he looks different. Third thing. Oh no.
I'm in a whole thing with this guy from Albuquerque and that really proper guy
named John Carlo Esposito is just like, I know who you are.
And then what happens in his he's in over his head. Oh. He can't get up. Bam.
Four seasons. Now what happens?
All the cancer's gone and Arab positive basement somewhere. Bam. Fifth season.
Now he's out for blood. He's not for blood because he has to kill everybody.
That's it, dude. If AMC was like, dude, we make money.
We're going to make you more money and you do more seasons. Then I go like this.
Well then guess what? Man, new characters,
new plot break it because we'll call it breaking bad. I don't give a.
It's about the shows about a shark now in captivity.
Yeah.
So yeah. I don't know. I mean, it's one thing. If it's a comfort show,
like if it's like what do you call it with the geeks on the, on ABC,
the most successful show of all time. The geeks,
they should just call that show geeks. What?
The it called with the guys who do the, all the dorks on the
[inaudible] [inaudible] the. Is it the guy won the Emmy for it?
Big bang theory is uncultured folks.
Big bang theory on CBS. Not on ABC and not called the geeks.
Okay.
Man. That's so awesome. Breaking bad as the. God. you, dude.
You know? And then people are like, you see the wire though? Yeah.
I saw the wire do it. All right. Why don't you just relax? I saw. Okay.
It's good. But relax. You compare a show to breaking bad. You get to step in,
dude. God that made King speech look.
Uh, what's his name? Stepping inside the ring. Cm punk.
I swear to God King speech.
Colin Firth saw Bryan Cranston make that phone call to his wife about how I did
it. And you had nothing to do with it.
When the phone was tapped and Colin Firth went like this, I like, Oh, all right,
it. I quit acting. That's what happened.
But yeah dude, I just can't believe good television. Ah,
those haters out there. I could have done it. I could have done it.
You know how hard is. How about the fact that they're the people that are,
that are doing it. You little. Huh? How about that?
They're the people that are doing it when I say, Oh, Ozark is good or outsiders.
Good. Yeah, but bro. Oh yeah. How about they did it?
How about they did it? Yeah.
[inaudible] yeah, but they did it. Dude.
Let's make this money even though we can't right now. Cause the Rona.